please be seated welcome to the plastics
ceremony celebrating the accomplishments
of the general studies class of 2011 I'm
especially pleased that President Lee
Bollinger provost Claude Steele
executive vice president nicholas dirks
and members of the faculty and
administration are here to share in our
celebration I would also like to welcome
our class days speaker Professor Roger
leads class of nineteen sixty six
finally it's my privilege to welcome our
reunion classes and the reunion
committee chaired this year by professor
Leeds who is celebrating his 45th
anniversary as a GS alumnus the creation
of GS over 60 years ago represents a
milestone in the evolution of
undergraduate education at elite
colleges and universities what makes GS
unique is that it actively recruit
students who have taken an untraditional
path to a traditional rigorous Ivy
League education the marriage of two
undergraduate colleges Columbia College
and GS 14 traditional students the other
for non-traditional students makes the
undergraduate classroom at Columbia
different from that of any other Ivy
League classroom
we value not only diversity of economic
background ethnic background race and
gender but also diversity of age and
experience we know for a fact that this
unique marriage contributes
significantly to the quality of the
intellectual discourse in the classroom
the success of GS and of this innovative
model of undergraduate education is due
in large part to the commitment of the
faculty to the ideal that an Ivy League
education should be available to
talented women and men at any point in
their lives it is in fact because of
this commitment the app that we have
been able to recruit to Columbia the
largest number of veterans at any Ivy
League university
22 of whom are celebrating their
graduation with us today weathered
weather GS students are dancers
entrepreneurs or firefighters Wall
Street bankers or technology specialists
whether they are in the challenging
joint program with list college of the
Jewish Theological Seminary working
parents or professional models whether
they are international students or new
Americans they receive their superb
Columbia education together with all
other Columbia undergraduates we're also
proud to announce that we have recruited
our first class of North American
students for the new dual VA program
between Columbia GS and the answer to de
toutes politique in Paris known more
commonly as CL SPO the premier french
university focusing on the study of
social science at seven campuses around
france our commitment to educational
innovation is not limited to the full
integration into the undergraduate
program of students with untraditional
backgrounds but also includes the
creation of innovative undergraduate
programs that are in tune with the
President's commitment to make Columbia
the leading global university in the
country if not the world members of the
class of 2011 you represent the cutting
edge of undergraduate education and you
have proven yourselves through your
academic accomplishments We are
privileged to count you as members of
the Columbia intellectual communities
and the alumni communities
yeah for yourself since he assumed the
presidency of Columbia in 2002 Lee
Bollinger has articulated a dynamic
vision for the future of this great
University and mobilized the human and
financial resources required to
transform that vision into reality in
the past nine years president Bollinger
has skillfully guided to completion the
approval approval process for Columbia's
ambitious expansion into manhattanville
in West Harlem where the first stages of
construction have already begun he
continues to enhance scientific research
embodied in the new science building and
the new tune to be constructed Center
for Neuroscience president Bollinger has
also moved columbia into the forefront
of international universities with the
establishment of columbia centers in key
cities around the world his goal is to
transform all levels of the university
its students curriculum and long-term
vision to embrace the values of global
engagement president Bollinger is also a
committed educator continuing to teach
an undergraduate course on the First
Amendment even while he leads this great
University it is my pleasure to
introduce to you the 19th president of
Columbia University Li si Bollinger
thank you very much Peter the the water
is unbelievable I just hope you can hear
us from up here I want to say a special
welcome and thanks to the parents and
families and friends of the graduates I
set where
I think everyone on the stage has set
where you are now and we all know just
how deeply emotional this moment and a
is and we we extend our great great
welcome to you you'll have a chance to
hear me not at great length but at some
length on Wednesday and so I just want
to say a couple of things to you today
first is I would like to give you the
opportunity to thank Dean Peter on
because he is an extraordinary adenine
has done so much to build general
studies to what it is today and it's not
only the intelligence that he brings to
it it's his character it's this person
it's his love of you and of general
studies so thank you very much Peter
just two things one is the institution
loves you and it loves you because you
represent what is best about the
university you represent what we feel
about knowledge about curiosity about
struggling to make sure that you improve
yourself in life by learning more so
every time we have you in our classes
every time we think about general
studies that little word non-traditional
which is such an odd word to apply to a
group of students but it means a lot to
us because what it means is people who
have not just done what so many of us
have done which sort of march on in life
and go to school and graduate and
receive another degree you
who have followed different paths in
life you have decided in some cases
against very high obstacles to return to
school and to continue in education to
learn more to build your knowledge build
a better life that's what we value so
much here and more than anyone else at
this institution you represent that and
the second point is I just can't imagine
a more exciting time yep that's the
second thing is I just can't imagine a
more exciting time in life to go out
into the world as it is it every day as
you read the paper as you travel as you
take horses as you think about things
you have to feel that the world is being
remade in ways that are fresh and new
with very significant problems ahead but
such enormous potential and for those of
us who have come from one life of the
1950s 60s through the 90s and seen the
Cold War end and and civil rights build
really an incredible society here issues
that dominated our attention of course
continue to do so but it is a really new
world that you will be living the rest
of your adult lives in and it just
couldn't give us more confidence to have
you be the people who will see this
through so both because you represent so
much that we value here and because it's
an exciting time for you and for us as
we build this new global society
especially on behalf of all of us we say
to congratulations class of 2011
Roger leads earned his PhD from Johns
Hopkins University we're currently he is
professor of International Finance at
the paul h nitsa school of advanced and
international studies he is director of
the Center for International Business
and public policy he also teaches at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and currently at the
Columbia Business School previously he
taught at the Harvard Kennedy School of
Government professor leads his
international career began over 40 years
ago soon after his graduation from GS
when he served in the Peace Corps in
Brazil since then he has worked in over
80 countries throughout Latin America
Asia Eastern Europe the former Soviet
Union and Africa prior to joining the
faculty of Johns Hopkins dr. Leeds was
managing managing director and co-head
of emerging markets practices at Patrick
off and company a New York venture
capital firm and merchant bank
previously he was a partner at kpmg
where he headed their global
privatization advisory services he began
his investment banking career here in
New York at Salomon Brothers in the
public sector Roger spent more than 10
years as a senior officer at the World
Bank working on debt and equity
financing of private sector projects
throughout the developing world over the
past dozen years Roger Leeds has
dedicated himself to teaching and
research on international finance
markets private equity and venture
capital in
sting in emerging markets and financial
sector development his publications are
far too numerous to list for you this
morning more important for us today is
the fact that throughout his world
travels an immensely distinguished
career roger has never lost his passion
for GS and its mission he is celebrating
the 45th anniversary of his graduation
and he is graciously serving as chair of
this year's reunion committee despite
being a finance and development person
roger is really a lot of fun feisty
funny and a truly fabulous human being
let us welcome our distinguished class
day speaker professor roger lee
Thank You Dean on and distinguished
faculty president Bollinger and of
course all of you and and your and your
parents and friends it's a great honor
to be here and I want to also as they
have before me offer my special
congratulations to each of you I
remember although it's been a long long
time sitting where you're sitting and
feeling how you're feeling believe it or
not I can still remember and so I
congratulate you and all your family and
friends that you have good reason to be
very very proud as you sit here today so
I join everybody else
I also want to say that in addition to
being extremely extremely honored to
have been asked to speak today at a
school which holds a very very special
place in my heart I was particularly
honored because I to light as president
Bollinger just said have an
extraordinary amount of admiration for
your Dean Peter on who i think has done
an extraordinary job here over his
tenure and all of us who are here today
and have been through the generations
part of the general studies family owe
him an enormous debt of gratitude
because i think he's been an
extraordinary gene
having said that about Peter who I
consider a friend and I respect
enormously I must confess that when he
extended his invitation to speak on this
very special occasion we almost got off
on the wrong foot when I asked him was
there anything particular that he'd like
me to speak about today on this special
occasion he suggested that I focus on my
own professional journey that I embarked
on after leaving where you're sitting
today some some 45 years ago and I
didn't say it to him at the time but I
did feel that this might not be the most
appropriate topic today even though I
was a student here I felt that you would
not be particularly captivated by
autobiography especially my own on such
a special occasion and that this would
not really captivate your attention is
me as much as possibly something some
other subject but to remain in the beans
good graces i will speak a little bit
about my own journey that took place
after i left here and what happened to
me professionally and peter has already
told you a little bit about that but
first let me begin by sharing a story of
more recent vintage a story that is less
about me but quintessentially
representative of this extraordinary
unique institution called the Columbia
University School of general studies to
those in the know GS a few months ago on
a bitter cold evening I had the
privilege of chairing as Peter suggested
a meeting of about a dozen or so alumni
representing various graduate classes
dating back more than 60 years to the
1950s and the purpose of the meeting
isn't particularly important but the
profiles of the individuals who SAT
around that table on that cold evening I
think is worth mentioning all we had in
common was that we had great
from GS and since we did not know each
other I asked each participant to
briefly recount how they had arrived
here at GS and reflect a bit on the
significance of their education at GS
long ago at first glance as I listen to
these stories each of the GS alumni were
not very different that most of those
undergraduates who are receiving
Columbia degrees today as you would
expect they were very very bright just
like you they were highly motivated to
succeed I presume like most of you and
they were Admiral lead to diverse in
terms of race and culture nationality
gender and more it also is a parents as
you might expect that each had traveled
a different professional path since
their graduation from GS into the arts
business medicine some went to
non-governmental organizations there
were even a few academics around the
table and all had achieved some level of
success in their chosen profession as I
listen to these extraordinarily diverse
personal stories however I struck more
by the common denominators that bound us
together than the differences
unknowingly each and their charm
magnified with their real why there
really is no other academic institution
quite like GS without exception each
personal story that evening began with
an outpouring of genuine appreciation to
general studies for offering them a
second chance although most were
reticent understandably about why this
was necessary that they needed this
second chance I surmised that for most
those pre GS years were not marked by
necessarily extraordinary academic
achievement that is the standard
prerequisite for admission to most to
all Ivy League schools it was crystal
clear that everyone at that table was
extraordinary grateful however to be
granted the opportunity to study here I
was really struck by the
genuine outpouring of appreciation I
also was struck that each storyteller
revealed an element of disbelief at
being emitted two gs almost as if they
were undeserving and something
approaching reverence for the
opportunity provided by the school
something I don't really see very often
in the other schools where I've been
associated with I should add that I most
definitely share this feeling of
appreciation equally significant as the
stories unfolded was the unanimity about
the meaning of the GS opportunity
without exception all expressed view
that their experience here at this
school represented the critical turning
point that literally changed their lives
invariably for the better I might add it
was this immense gratitude that
motivated each of them to venture out
after a long work day on that februari
evening and many he are here and many
are here today I believe and they bought
with them a simple message I want to
give back although decades have gone by
since my days at GS I cannot and I will
not forget where I came from war the
institution that gave me the opportunity
deserve it or not to make something of
myself that was the message of that
evening from everybody and ladies and
gentlemen that to me is the GS story and
although my own professional journey was
as different as everyone else who
attended that gathering was exactly the
same in one dimension that has
transpired in the last forty years or so
and it began right here on this campus
my GS education was the essential
catalyst for just about everything that
followed in my life based on my own
academic performance before arriving at
GS it's fair to say that I gave new
meaning to the term late Luke late
bloomer pre GS
the bulk of my energy and attention was
devoted to achieving success on the
athletic field and shall we say in
teenage social circles we can skip the
details of this early history you'll be
glad phul that I do but I will reveal
that my mom passed her entire lifetime
in a state of disbelief that somehow I
had managed to gain admission to
Columbia here although although she
never met the misguided admission
officer who opened the GS gates to her
son there's no doubt in my mind that had
the opportunity arisen she would have
genuflecting before him with the same
reverence that god-fearing Catholics
give to the Pope she was constantly
amazed I'm going to have to talk very
very loud to compete with this out for
Peter did you order this huh
and so I arrived at GS unprepared under
confident but very determined that this
was my second chance and I too was
determined to take full advantage
I don't know what this says about your
future but I think I think I hope it's a
good sign
one one thing you learn is you how to
deal with adversity that's what you
learn what I don't know if it's in your
classroom but certainly you learn that
here so in my early 20s for the very
first time I began to study here at GS
with a seriousness of purpose through my
GS professors became attracted to a
range of subjects that eventually became
my life's work as Peter said after all
it was the 60s the Cold War was at its
height the campus was a beehive of
raucous debate both in the classroom and
out looking back now it seems only
natural that given the ferment of the
era I would gravitate here GS two
courses and government international
relations and basic economics and most
importantly it was here at GS the seeds
of inquiry we were first planted and
that started at what started as an
intellectual curiosity quickly became a
career path and that was as Peter said
in the field of international
development in these classrooms that you
attend date where you attended class for
example I started to ask the same
questions that preoccupy me even today
why do some countries develop while
others remain stubbornly mired in
poverty what are the linkages between
political and economic development are
some political systems more likely to
foster economic development than others
think of China for example where does
the essential dimension of culture fit
into the puzzle about why some countries
and regions develop more quickly than
others this foreign aid really make a
difference in the pace and direction of
a country's development I first started
asking these questions way back then and
by the time I graduated although just
beginning to grapple with these issues I
finally had a sense of purpose thanks to
what I began to study here at GS and
although the career path details were
still blurred in my own mind I knew that
working in developing countries would be
a part of my future
when I reflect on this critical decision
and it says a lot as much about the
times is the individual after all back
then I was emblematic of the generation
that was captivated captivated by JFK's
familiar eloquent and compelling call to
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country for
me and for so many others it resume
resonated almost like a command and so I
obeyed and as Peter said in his very
gracious introduction a few weeks after
graduating from GS I was sworn in as a
Peace Corps volunteer and left family
and friends for more than two years for
rural Brazil and the beginning of my
so-called career this too was a
life-changing experience but I still
think that it even today that it was
validated first and started here by what
I learned at GS upon my return from
Brazil as Peter explained I did get a
doctorate at and then I started on what
was a very zigzag career took me back
and forth to the public in the private
sector with stops along the way in
academia but it was a very zigzag career
as I went the common thread throughout
this professional journey however has
been my interest in developing countries
more specifically I became interested in
the intersect between public policy and
the private sectors role as a catalyst
or an inhibitor of economic growth and
development to put it slightly
differently almost everything I've done
professionally public sector private
sector academically has confirmed my
belief that the debilitating scourge of
global poverty can only be mitigated by
when the private sector plays a
constructive role as a driver of
economic growth and development and this
in turn is I have witnessed repeatedly
only happens when government designs and
impulse implements good pub
policy and that has been basically what
I have focused on throughout my long
career Dean on being on will forgive me
I hope if I skip over the details of
this professional Odyssey from the
poorest of the poor to countries that
are on the cusp of joining the first
world the most advanced countries of the
world but suffice to say that I've had
the very good fortune I feel blessed to
have dealt with a broad range of
extraordinary complex and interesting
development issues and I've had also the
privilege to collaborate with an
unforgettable cast of practitioners from
both the public and the private sector
throughout this long career and I really
do feel that I have learned as much from
them as from the other experiences that
I've had and that has also been a great
great privilege of mine and then about
ten years ago the profession of my
professional journey took as Peter
suggested a very sharp turn when my
phone rang unexpectedly and I was
offered an opportunity to join the
faculty of the Johns Hopkins School of
Advanced International Studies I like to
characterize this job offer as my chance
to become poor and happy and I'm pleased
to report that I have achieved both
objectives with not a moment's regret in
a way this final professional chapter
brought me full circle to where it all
began back here at Columbia and drew yes
when briefly I suppose I was an academic
of sorts just like you thinking about
today in this process of circling back
to where it all began has reminded me of
the Reverend William Sloane coffin the
iconic chaplain who presided for many
years right up the street from here at
Riverside Church I hope some of you at
least recognize that name because of my
ear everybody knew William Sloane coffin
he was revered
by many of my generation we who were the
rabble-rousing children of the 60s
hell-bent on changing the world shortly
before his death a few years ago he
wrote a thin but extraordinary book
called letters to a young doubter which
was an imaginary exchange of
correspondence between him in his old
age and a college student who was asking
questions about life during a period of
great uncertainty perhaps I don't know
for sure some of you may identify with
that maybe he resembles some of you like
coffins imaginary student it's just
possible that today you two are coping
with a modicum of tension on the one
hand there is well-deserved pride and
joy that comes with graduation but on
the other perhaps there's just some
troubling uncertainty or doubts about
your future if you fall within this
category coffins book provides a very
useful insight don't be anxious about
your doubts he counsels doubts move you
forward not backward just don't seek or
expect certainty absolute certainty
coffin goes on to suggest that the most
important question all of us have to
address one that is extraordinarily
difficult to answer but essential to ask
is who tells you who you are and if you
think about the question the answer is
quite obvious it's not your parents with
all due respect it's not your favorite
teacher with all due respect it's not
your best friend or your spouse who
tells you are who you are is you it may
take a lifetime to gain some clarity if
not certainty on this extraordinarily
complex question but in my view it is
imperative that each one of you take on
this introspective quest of
self-discovery or in coffins words know
thyself for me and I think many other GS
alumni who attended that februari
meeting a few
months ago the quest began right here
right here at GS it was here that our
minds began to open that we began to ask
questions that raised as many doubts as
answers and it was GS that gave us
license to begin our own journey of
self-discovery I can only hope that each
of you years from now will reflect on
your GS experience and appreciate that
for you too it started right here and if
you do no matter how successful you
become and each of you will determine
success in your own way don't forget
please don't forget that like me and so
many others before you whether it was
your first chance your second chance or
maybe even your third chance it started
right here at general studies
congratulations and thank you very very
much and it stopped playing
thank you so much professor Leeds Elias
Shackleford began his career as a
concert pianist at a very young age when
his aunt a Columbia alumna gave him a
month of piano lessons as a gift at 18
he began a full-time performance career
since then he has given more than 2,500
concerts including over 20 performances
at the White House Elliot transferred to
GS from georgia perimeter college and
brought with him not just a passion for
learning but also a southern charm and
gentility that is refreshing for us
harden new yorkers at Columbia Elliot
has been fully immersed in the
intellectual life of the University and
the community life of the campus he's
been a regular tour guide served on the
student council actively participated in
the international relations forum and
political science students association
he's also served with me and other
faculty colleagues on the committee on
instruction the faculty committee that
governs the entire undergraduate
curriculum at Columbia Elliot
Shackleford graduate summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa a member of the GS honor
society with honors in political science
next year you will be attending law
school I am privileged to present to you
the salutatorian of the class of 2011 d
Elliot Shackleford
Thank You Dean on president Bollinger
Provost's steel executive vice president
Dirk's d non-faculty families friends
classmates and a special welcome to our
class day speaker professor roger leads
i have never been more honored to step
onto a stage than I am today with my
fellow graduates of the class of 2011
this is the day that we've all been
working toward for a very long time
today is a celebration of that effort
and recognition of the years of work and
anticipation it's also an
acknowledgement of the support of
faculty administration and those close
to us who are with us today the people
who have been unreservedly invested in
our accomplishment who supported us
academically and personally and without
whom it would have been a far more
difficult if not impossible challenge to
overcome we've been called the dancer
the journalist the supermodel the mom
the business exec the soldier and so
many other fascinating identities at
times in the past these distinctions
have created a lack of common experience
between us and everyone else around us
we have been known as so many different
things and yet we have shared a common
goal during our time on this campus the
degree that we receive today and so
today and for the rest of our lives we
also share the identity of being
Columbia graduates and that will never
change
our time as students in the school of
general studies has provided an
incredible exchange of perspectives as
we've learned from each other an
adventure providing uniquely
thought-provoking and sometimes rather
interesting experiences I still remember
talking with a professor after a class
in which we had discussed the fall of
the Berlin Wall when we both suddenly
realized that we had watched that event
live on television went before many
people in the class had even been born
there's nothing like taking a course
about security strategies with a
military veteran who has been on the
ground and seen the situation firsthand
and there's nothing like studying social
justice with a community organizer and a
financial analyst but our education
hasn't come just from being surrounded
by interesting or brilliant or diverse
people it's the camaraderie within a
shared vision it's about people who have
known and done so many different things
who come together and say there are so
many things that I still don't know the
reason that we're all here the reason
that we're all in the same graduating
class is that at some point together or
separately we've said I want to know
more at this particular place at this
particular time in this particular way
people often ask how a pianist becomes a
political scientist but this kind of
transition is really the norm at GS
among the many amazing people that I've
met are Rob cow d who left the business
world because he had always wanted to
study film and Stephen Tobias who
graduated last year with a degree in
English after having built a successful
brokerage firm and he also happened to
be at GS at the same time
mrs. daughter general studies students
have learned throughout life through
experience and searching for every
opportunity to gain new knowledge this
is why we came to GS to be in an
atmosphere where this discovery is the
central focus we are here today because
we wanted to have the ideas to explore
the opportunities to try new things and
at times to fall short and then go on to
succeed all within a class period or a
semester or the entirety of our time at
Columbia like dr. Leeds I think many of
us were initially uncertain about
whether general studies really should
have accepted us for admission but
eventually my disbelief at being here
being at Columbia University actually
ended up being a reassurance I still
remember standing at the window of can't
halt after my Chinese literature class
in my first semester completely
overwhelmed by how much there was to
learn how much there was to write and
above all how incredibly much there
always was to read then when I looked
out over campus I remember thinking to
myself this is Columbia I'm at Columbia
and there's no way I could have ever
expected to be here ever since I first
walked through the Amsterdam gate and
the reason it was the Amsterdam gate is
because I got lost in Harlem on the way
to campus the two train you know ever
since I walked through that gate I've
been conscious of the tradition of
excellence in education at the highest
level that pervades this very special
place the inscription at the top of low
library has never failed to give me
chills because although this
is our day our celebration it is also a
celebration of something that is ongoing
when we walk across this stage in a few
minutes we will become part of a
tradition that as the inscription says
has been maintained and cherished from
generation to generation our being here
today is the culmination of the
investment of the people who came before
us and a little investment of our own
too but our time and accomplishment at
Columbia and the things that we choose
to do after it is likewise an investment
in those who will become part of this
tradition in the future in a way the
legacy of our time at Columbia is in
what it has changed and will continue to
change about who we already were I had
done a lot of traveling before coming to
GS as a concert pianist it goes with the
territory but exploring the world in the
classrooms of hamilton hall or in the
stacks of butler library truly expanded
my perspective through the ideas of
professors conversations with TAS the
opinions of my classmates and
innumerable books and articles I was
given a gift I was allowed to stop being
an intellectual tourist the world has
always been accessible in between us
we've seen most of it but even familiar
places are now intellectually available
to us in a way that they have never been
before I've always been partial to TS
Eliot for obvious reasons and he
captured this idea when he wrote we
shall not cease from exploration and the
end of all our exploring
will be to arrive where we started and
to know the place for the first time the
things that we still want to know are
out there waiting to be known and we
have now developed a constantly evolving
consciousness that will allow us to
explore and to better understand a world
with countless facets when I first
started playing the piano when I was
five years old I remember having to sit
on a stack of telephone books in order
to reach the keys straining to see the
notes on the sheet music with my legs
dangling above the floor I remember how
excited I was when I was at last able to
sit on the bench with my feet flat on
the floor at times over the past few
years I felt like I was carrying those
telephone books around with me as I
dragged my bag from class to class but
now now none of us needs the telephone
books and it's time to just look out
over the top of the piano toward the
audience and just play for them and also
for ourselves I believe it's
conventional at commencements to talk
about going out and changing the world
that there is an obligation that must be
fulfilled the exciting thing to me
though is that this challenge can also
be an opportunity we don't have to think
about changing the world just by
graduating we already have we were on a
certain path we had a certain story and
not only did we change it but we learned
that we can and therefore we can again
and people who are like us and unlike us
can make that same change for themselves
our Columbia education has given us a
foundation for whatever we do to change
things
from now on the opportunity is not
automatic the things that we can
accomplish will not just happen but the
deliberate action it takes to get there
is now more familiar it is what
stimulated the decision to come to GS
and what gave us the ability to get up
every day to stay in the library an
extra hour to write those extra few
pages many of us here know what failure
feels like but fear and doubt smell like
what uncertainty and disappointment
taste like and yet not a single one of
us knows about giving up which is why
we're here today and all of you know
what success looks like because it
looked back at you from the mirror this
morning and you can see it sitting on
either side of you right now
and this is how it should be many of you
have been in class with me or right next
to me writing a paper at 3am and a
lounge or freaking out about the paper
you should have been writing at 3am in
the lounge maybe we weren't as well
rested as clean shaven or as well
dressed as we are today but that that is
what success looked like to no matter
the individual struggles we faced or the
different lives that we lived one of the
things that binds together our
experiences is that we did it we went to
class more often than not we turned in
our assignments and we finished our
semesters it really is an unbelievable
accomplishment and also an act of faith
since we believed in ourselves our ideas
and the sometimes all consuming process
that is a Columbia education we believed
enough to say that it is worth it as an
investment in our minds in our futures
and in ourselves I still remember my
first connection with GS students
through an online community called
storybook on the school's website it was
filled with all sorts of advice that
made me wonder if I was really ready for
this experience because as I read
through it I kept thinking to myself
well I hadn't thought of this why didn't
I consider that but what enchanted me
was that this was my very first
experience interacting with the aspect
of GS that had originally attracted me
the completely different stories that we
all were bringing into this place CS
Lewis wrote that friendship is born at
that moment when one person says to
another
what you too I thought I was the only
one which I think perfectly applies to
our school together we have continued
our distinct narratives here at general
studies and Columbia substantially
changing them for the to be continued
the next chapter the next volume in the
series that lies ahead today I'm
graduating with some of you who i met on
the story book website before we arrived
and many others who came both before and
after we are coming to an end of this
chapter in all of its comedy and drama
and the exciting thing is so much more
of the story still lies in the future
and so once again I applaud you my
fellow graduates I wish you the very
best in your future stories and I want
to say again that it is my privilege to
be a part of this outstanding class the
class of 2011 thank you
come up right here each year the Alumni
key is bestowed on a senior who has
achieved distinction both academically
and through service to the school and
the undergraduate community were
fortunate to have two wonderful
recipients of the Alumni key award this
year Professor Roger leads our
distinguished alumnus and class day
speaker will present the award Henry
Wells was born and raised in the United
Kingdom where he attended boarding
schools from the age of 10 at 13 he was
accepted to Eton College from an early
age Henry was fascinated by other
peoples and cultures and vowed to turn
that fascination into real-life
experience after graduating from prep
school he taught English in Peru to
indigenous peoples in the Amazon Henry
participated in Christian outreach
programs in Germany and spent time in
Jerusalem learning Hebrew and studying
Judaism Henry applied two gs to be able
to immerse himself in American culture
and education which he did with gusto he
served on the student council council as
international student representative and
senior class president he led the effort
on the senior gift which this year had a
record high participation of almost
fifty percent that is pretty good
Henry also volunteered at Community
Impact Columbia social and educational
outreach organization he will graduate
from the Department of Middle East South
Asian and African Studies in October
with Latin honors Phi Beta Kappa and as
a member of the GS Honor Society
congratulations Henry
congratulations Henry best of luck don't
forget the award oh Henry I give you the
wrong one we take it thank you I'm old
our second alumni key recipient is now
familiar to you our salutatorian Elliot
Shackleford Elliot has served in a
number of capacities on the student
council worked as a mentor of new GF
students volunteered at Columbia
community outreach New York Cares
jumpstart New York artists reaching out
love kitchen among others welcome again
our second alumni key recipient Elliot
Shackleford
good morning my name is Leslie Lamar
dough and I am the acting dean of
students at the school of general
studies present president Bollinger
Provost steel executive vice president
Dirk's Dean on professor leaves
distinguished faculty dedicated alumni
and assembled guests it is my pleasure
to present to you our candidates for The
Bachelor of Arts the bachelor of arts
and bachelor of science in the school of
general studies class of 2011
each each degree candidate will receive
a certificate of achievement from
president Bollinger with a special
moment captured on film by our
photographers it's important special
moments dr. roger leads class of 66 will
present each graduate with the GS alumni
pin seniors wear this pin with pride and
let it serve as a reminder of your
academic achievement and the time you
spent a GS to the wonderful supportive
and vocal family and friends that have
gathered today I humbly ask that you
please hold your applause until all the
graduates have been presented on stage
we would not want to have one family's
excitement drown out the presentation of
another proud families graduate I
promise you there will be plenty of
opportunities for applause and
celebration when the presentation of the
class of 2011 is complete thank you so
much for your understanding and
restraint with a few exceptions here and
there this year's class will be
presented in alphabetical order
approximately will the class will the
candidates for the degree of Bachelor of
Arts and Bachelor of Science please step
forward
Sierra Bree Bayless Bachelor of Arts
Women's Studies department to honors
magna laude Phi Beta Kappa Henry
Weston henry charles western wells
Bachelor of Arts with a double major
middle eastern South Asian and African
Studies political science Phi Beta Kappa
Christina wells Bachelor of Arts
political science with a special
concentration in human rights marketa
Denise a cron Bachelor of Arts
african-american studies laude Chris
Lee I Dean Bachelor of Arts biological
sciences laude zelphia pole Bachelor
of Arts economics with a special
concentration in sustainable development
Stephen Christopher Adams bachelor of
arts economics koku okposo bachelor of
arts major mathematics and statistics
horrible mahato says so bachelor of arts
economics jeffrey Scott Anderson
bachelor of arts political science
Elliot Shackleford Bachelor of Arts
political science summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Kira Alicia bosch bachelor of
arts psychology summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa moment Arlene bachelor of arts
economics and mathematics Olga min
afford bachelor of arts neuroscience and
behavior laude youssef ben o'them I
said bachelor of arts middle eastern
south asian and african studies with
departmental honors alpha osman bah
bachelor of science computer science
with a concentration in political
science preston george zucco baliga
bachelor of arts psychology laude
Stephen August Barton bachelor of
science environmental science with a
special concentration in sustainable
development Dylan Michael Bartlett
bachelor of arts history magna
laude christopher Carl Randall Bella
zoo bachelor of arts urban studies
Rachel & Berkowitz Bachelor of Arts
economics with a concentration in
psychology magna laude Eddie bursac
bachelor of arts film studies Benjamin
Adam Burnett bachelor of arts
biochemistry laude Aaron cardo carlo
bloomfield the bachelor of arts english
Peter William Bodnar the third bachelor
of arts with a double major in American
Studies and political science cassia
Burke Bachelor of Arts French and Franco
study francophone studies summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa michael william
burton bachelor of arts political
science ryan joseph Burwell bachelor of
arts theater arts Evan Carter bachelor
of arts political science to gender
Tsing sha how bachelor of arts
psychology Clark Shaheen bachelor of
arts economics Sabrina Lee buckwalter
bachelor of arts political science Jacob
Bernard Aaron bachelor of arts middle
eastern South Asian and African Studies
Sherman mian qiang bachelor of arts
economics mathematics laude Marcus
chin bachelor of arts economics
Stephanie Lee chu bachelor of arts
economics with a concentration in
political science Maya poppy young
Funaki bachelor of arts economics
departments who honors summa laude
Phi Beta Kappa Simeon leave Cohen
bachelor of arts philosophy laude
Aaron Jacob Cole bachelor of arts urban
studies magna laude William Michael
William Cole bachelor of arts history
jennifer marie Cecil Conrad bachelor of
arts anthropology Leah Sarah Curtis
bachelor of arts anthropology
departmental honors laude Frank
Andrew
bachelor of arts urban studies Ralph
Thomas is a bachelor of arts english
Stephen Kevin D'Alessio bachelor of arts
history klar Leopold to Shepherd
Bachelor of Arts interdisciplinary
science and sustainable development
laude Lauren Louise Giovanni bachelor of
arts history Michael ap Hayes Bachelor
of Arts political science joseph andrew
do acts bachelor of arts history andrew
david edwards bachelor of arts history
with departmental honors summa laude
Phi Beta Kappa samuel george l Curt
bachelor vaart with a double major in
creative writing and philosophy magna
laude Shana Faye Bush Bachelor of
Arts biophysics Ariana Fargo bachelor of
arts english magna laude Benjamin
David Phil Phil woman bachelor of arts
political science with a concentration
in history laude Martha II
Fitzgerald Bachelor of Arts creative
writing summa laude arres mardukan
Bachelor of Arts economics mathematics
summa laude Kevin Lawrence flora
Bachelor of Arts economics and political
science claire marie collect Ford
Bachelor of Arts psychology Nicholas
Joseph godec bachelor of arts history
laude ashley nicole Gregor stoner
Bachelor of Arts political science Phi
Beta Kappa Elena Grady Akina Bachelor of
Arts computer science Karen more green
Bachelor of Arts political science
Daniel Matthew Epstein batch levorg
sociology department to honors magna
laude Justin Trevor Patrick Humphries
Bachelor of Arts political science
laude Joseph Francis gagan bachelor
of arts english Leah Francesca Gerber
Bachelor of Arts classical studies max
Joseph grows Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics with a concentration in
Russian languages and cultures magna
laude Nicole miles grinder Bachelor of
Arts in English departmental honors with
a concentration in art history magna
laude Anna fielding Griggs Bachelor of
Arts anthropology department to honors
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Lee a lot
Carlin Bachelor of Arts with a double
major in economics mathematics and
psychology yo of Orion Bachelor of Arts
East Asian Studies laude Tamara
Apple Apple Baum Bachelor of Arts
political science Miyagi goo bachelor of
arts economics is statistics Jason David
Gustafson Bachelor of Arts political
science lior Moshe hackle Bachelor of
Arts neuroscience and behavior
departmental honors summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Jimmy hang bachelor of arts
film studies with a concentration
American Studies laude Spencer James
had our bachelor of arts American
Studies Jack David Hindle bran bachelor
of arts english andrea lynn 'i know
Xhosa bachelor of arts history tour
concentration in archaeology Brian
Michael holler Bachelor of Arts
philosophy hi rehne hung Bachelor of
Arts economics laude Mitchell Reagan
hulse bachelor arts history andrew
charles greane bachelor of arts art
history summa laude very Nicole
Siegel Bachelor of Arts economics with a
special concentration and sustainable
development Bethany Denise ribs Bachelor
of Arts creative writing
magna laude special concentration
and sustainable development Samantha
marine Jackson bachelor of arts African
Studies Jonathan Arthur Jaeger bachelor
of arts english laude eric johnson
batch of arts economics l'shana rasha
johnson bachelor of arts East Asian
Studies Mickey boy Coffman bachelor of
arts history summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa David O'Shea Keithley bachelor of
arts Financial Economics lakshmi
gopalaswami smog no laude Curran
Smith Kent Bachelor of Arts middle
eastern South Asian and African Studies
michael Stone kester bachelor of arts
computer science laude Diana Miriam
khatib bachelor of arts political
science Joshua Johnson Kirkpatrick
bachelor of arts history hello Zamir
knigsberg bachelor of arts sociology
laude cresta Suzanne Kruger bachelor
of arts creative writing magna laude
Andrew ass would cry Zack bachelor of
arts history James Francisco kosher
bachelor of arts American Studies magna
laude flora rose Whitman bachelor of
arts film studies paul quan bachelor of
arts economics lior hemi bachelor of
arts economics mathematics Samantha
Britt labrin bachelor of arts
architecture magna laude Erin Murray
LeMay bachelor of arts psychology Rachel
Dorothy Dorothea liao bachelor of arts
creative writing magna laude Jason
Wayne lamu bachelor of arts political
science laude sarah jane Lockwood
bachelor of arts political signs with
departmental honors
macomb laude Phi Beta Kappa Andre
melissa leu one bachelor of arts our
history laude alexandra rife lukens
bachelor of arts creative writing re al
Lia fight bachelor of arts urban studies
yonatan lev grossman boater bachelor of
arts history magna laude Jamie
Julian Martin bachelor of arts political
science Fidel milena bachelor of arts
political science Camille Santa iglesia
mask arenas bachelor of arts economics
Christina Barbara matteson baron
bachelor of science environmental
biology John herro McClelland the second
bachelor of arts history Todd Ian McCoy
bachelor of arts history Corinne
Roseanne mukha bachelor of arts
economics Jonathan mukai bachelor of
arts anthropology laude Michelle
mullahs Bachelor of Arts italian
cultural studies rose Ellen merges
bachelor of arts history magna laude
Kristen Allison hutzler bachelor of
science neuroscience and behavior and
Andrea Robin Gerson bachelor of arts
psychology Eric Walter Nyad nuh bachelor
of arts history laude mark Phillip
the Knicks Bachelor of Arts and rapala g
Katrin knows hold a flirt bachelor of
arts english summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa Allah o Donoghue bachelor of arts
art history and sociology Brian Richard
O'Hagan bachelor of arts psychology
Nathan page bachelor of arts political
science Ryan k young parch park back
bachelor of arts psychology Lucas
glasser Huffman bachelor of arts film
studies with departmental honors
laude Susan sung Park Bachelor of
Arts psychology Jennifer Lee Parker
Bachelor of Arts political science magna
laude Lisa Elena Parsons Bachelor of
Arts sociology laude the cre 0 Perez
bachelor of arts economics kiara read
bachelor of arts economics political
science Odelia rebel and nandez bachelor
of arts political science Julia Diane
Rubin bachelor of arts psychology
departmental honors with a concentration
in sociology summa laude Lucas David
Richards Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude bar reis
Bachelor of Arts philosophy laude
Barbara Roby bachelor of arts history
magna laude Marie Kathleen yague
tika bachelor of arts creative writing
laude benjamin lee neder bachelor of
arts american studies rotstein gone
claves roca bachelor of arts
neuroscience and behavior james herbert
romberger Bachelor of Arts visual arts
magna laude Brendan Keith Rooney
Bachelor of Arts political science
Armand richard rosen bachelor of arts
english magna laude mark david
Rosenthal bachelor of arts economics
Rodney Brooks Russell bachelor of arts
religion Sarah devorah session bachelor
of arts anthropology amitha Rebecca
Isaac Bachelor of Arts French Yotam
straynjer bachelor of arts economics
mathematics magna laude Phi Beta
Kappa Xavier Sabah Dara bachelor of arts
economics taio she Sato bachelor
arts economics brian dean said ovitch
bachelor of arts regional studies with
departmental honors summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Rafael Antonio Saldana
bachelor of arts political science
Theodore Edward mandinga shemeka
bachelor of arts history pill Hwang soo
bachelor of arts economics Raonic ave c
bachelor of arts economics mathematics
amir ahmad shah korean bachelor of arts
political science magna laude Jacob
Wayne shifflett bachelor of arts history
with a special concentration in human
rights Alex Alex Jacob cats Bachelor of
Arts psychology laude Shana t
sahayak Bachelor of Arts political
science he took Shin Bachelor of Arts
economics heather Lynn shorey Bachelor
of Arts anthropology Sophia see you
bachelor of arts economics with a
special concentration and sustainable
development Julia and Murphy bachelor of
arts sociology Xena attar bachelor of
arts sociology magna laude Phi Beta
Kappa Sara Elizabeth adri bachelor of
science to neuroscience and behavior
misty make Misty May dawn M bring
bachelor signs to neuroscience and
behavior magna laude katherine joy
Johnson bachelor science neuroscience
and behavior David the marine Sal a
Bachelor of Arts political science with
a special concentration in human rights
Maria Marcia McAllister Sherpa Bachelor
of Arts political science department to
honors laude Francis Petrie Bachelor
of Arts political science
Joseph Ephraim spits bachelor of arts
history magna laude Rebecca Taylor
Bachelor of Arts creative writing magna
laude Pamela gene steinberg bachelor
of arts english kevin lee Stendahl
bachelor of arts history Lauren Morgan
see moresee Sturgis bachelor of arts art
history christina marie sweet bachelor
of arts anthropology with departmental
honors magna laude Phi Beta Kappa
Shelly gene Sabo Bachelor of Arts
psychology michael alexander landis
bachelor of arts political science
laude shana aaron flink bachelor of arts
anthropology laude Samantha Jill
Shaffer bachelor of arts art history
laude Amy Schultz Bachelor of Arts
anthropology magna laude rachel anna
Spencer Bachelor of Arts anthropology
magna laude Christian tema bachelor
of arts German literature and culture
history departmental honors with a
concentration in psychology magna
laude Benjamin total shock bachelor of
arts political science laude kenzo
tsushima bachelor of arts philosophy shy
moshe sakal sokolow silverman bachelor
of arts history magna laude samuel a
frame kerbal bachelor of arts english
department to honors summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa farida boomer ova Bachelor of
Arts economics and political science
laude Paolina a vas Collins Bachelor of
Arts political science with a
concentration in psychology William John
villainous bachelor of arts english Eric
Matthew van Sileo Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences
matthew lee wall bachelor of arts
philosophy william david wang bachelor
of arts economics operations research
you mean Watanuki bachelor of arts
religion Geraldine Ashley we bachelor of
arts philosophy laude Adam Wyler
Bachelor of Arts classical studies
Bettina whiner bachelor of arts english
magna laude Phi Beta Kappa worry max
minnis bachelor of arts middle eastern
South Asian and African Studies summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Baribeau
Williams bachelor of arts political
science Natalia Bianca Wilson bachelor
of arts sociology Esther wolf bachelor
of arts mathematics Gabrielle Stephen
yup on such Bachelor of Science
evolutionary biology of the human
species departmental honors summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Laurey Williams
Sanford Bachelor of Arts psychology
joseph andrew yen such Bachelor of Arts
with a double major in creative writing
in English magna laude melissa r a
youngin blacher science chemistry Sarah
Tamsin ZIFT Bachelor of Arts political
science Nathan Meyer Miller bachelor of
science computer science laude mina
lee bachelor of arts economics and
statistics markridge una curtains Todd's
here bachelor Science Information
science Olaf Sigmund mati bachelor of
science economics holly marie de Lisle
bachelor of arts political science long
Gwen bachelor of science to neuroscience
and behavior
yonatan David need of Bachelor of Arts
religion k young lee bachelor of science
applied mathematics Monica Kirsten ova
Bachelor of Arts psychology Arielle
teacher bachelor of science computer
science cristiana hovik warwick bachelor
of arts psychology anupam mohanty
bachelor of arts political science kenza
peerzada bachelor of arts Middle Eastern
and south asian and african studies with
a concentration in pre medical sciences
james thomas cannon bachelor of arts
with a double major in philosophy and
psychology Michael Vincent tren bachelor
of arts sociology laude Edward wing
nigro bachelor of arts philosophy
andreya triana bachelor of arts
economics google rios garcia bachelor of
arts political science with a special
concentration in human rights Igor
torres de nascimento bachelor of arts
political science nemanja Mladenovic
bachelor of arts with a double major in
philosophy and political science summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Fabian Donald
foot Mueller Bachelor of Arts middle
eastern South Asian and African Studies
magna laude Andrew benjamin lee lane
junior bachelor of arts political
science deborah jan more bachelor of
arts film studies departmental honors
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Christine
Nicole mchone Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude Jove Meyer
bachelor of arts political science
laude Jesse ray hollister bachelor of
arts political science laude yavin
mihaylo stay on ovitch bachelor of arts
panic studies with a concentration in
linguistics summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa tiara Nicole winter shore Bachelor
of Arts creative writing laude some
we hung Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics Joshua Joshua lien Aaron
Anderson Bachelor of Arts psychology
Robert Nia V&M ski bachelor of arts for
philosophy laude michael sean kaplan
Hennessey the second bachelor of arts
eats asian studies Gabriel Nachman seed
bachelor of arts history laude
Samuel Jacob yongchun bachelor of arts
history concentration and pre medical
sciences laude Seth Ryan Samuels
Bachelor of Arts urban studies with
departmental honors summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Jacob slaven Levin fell
bachelor of arts history laude re
Siegel bachelor of arts urban studies
laude Alexandra Ross karina bachelor
of arts english laude krista sofa
now ski bachelor of arts political
science Lorna Althea woodham bachelor of
arts and through polishing Darrow Irene
lean Bachelor of Arts anthropology with
a concentration in comparative ethnic
studies Wendy Gail Dickinson bachelor of
arts english with a concentration in
anthropology magna laude inna
bollock bachelor of arts english Sofia
Eleanor Nemer bachelor of arts political
science Damien a de Gracia bachelor of
arts sociology Alberto Ricardo vadiya
bachelor of arts economics Jason Bay
bachelor of arts economics mathematics
Angus timpson Bachelor of Arts visual
arts Justin Ross turetsky Bachelor of
Arts political science laude Jonah
Hodari Robbins leben Bachelor of Arts
middle eastern South Asian African
Studies Jody Alexander Zelman Bachelor
of Arts and through pology magna
laude will the class
well the class well the class of 2011
please rise
thank you please be seated before coming
to columbia Kira Bush had a successful
career as a classical ballet dancer
she'd been trained at the School of
American Ballet Ballet Academy east and
the London studio center while at GS
here a majored in psychology and was
admitted to the prestigious psychology
department Honors Program in fact two of
the three graduating seniors in the
psychology honors program this year RGS
students and Jia students will be among
the honors psychology graduates next
year as well Kira was a much loved
teaching assistant in the introductory
psychology course before working with
young Chui before and during her time at
GS Kira dedicated herself to working
with young children she also served as a
research assistant at the bar nerd
toddler center Kira embodies in so many
wonderful ways the long and immensely
distinguished tradition of student
dancers at GS she is creative
disciplined and passionate about her
intellectual pursuits no matter how
difficult or demanding Kira bush
graduates would have with a better than
a average honours in psychology summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa and as a member
of the GS Honor Society next year she
will be pursuing a degree in psychology
a PhD specializing in child psychology
please join me in welcoming to the
podium
valedictorian of the class of 2011 Kira
both
president Bollinger provost steel
executive vice president Dirk's Dean on
faculty family and friends I am honored
to be addressing you today I am
enormously proud to be a member of the
group sitting in front of me right now
as a group of general studies graduates
we are known for the ways in which we
are distinct from traditional
undergraduates and from one another we
began our studies here at various times
and at different moments in our lives
some of us have children others of us
are just transitioning out of seeing
ourselves as children however our
diversity does not hinder us from being
a coherent group today I will share with
you my story in the service of
celebrating both our differences and
what we share today's graduating class
has members from all parts of the
country and the world from France Israel
and Switzerland from Atlanta california
and michigan I on the other hand grew up
18 blocks away my journey could have
been relatively short yet like many of
my fellow graduates the distances I
found myself traveling in order to be
here today were not just physical
distances traversing those 18 blocks
involved a five-year long detour to
England and Germany and a career as a
ballet dancer when I arrived to GS my
life had been divided for as long as I
could remember on the one hand
I attended PS 87 and is 44 and took my
studies very seriously on the other hand
since the age of eight I spent almost
every afternoon training to be a
professional ballet dancer there was not
much overlap between my two worlds very
few children at my ballet school went to
public schools like mine and the only
other public school student I knew who
studied ballet as seriously as i did was
my sister so I became used to belonging
and also used to not belonging with in
two separate universes at the age of 14
I was told I had to choose the ballet
world demands unfaltering dedication and
it was made clear to me that choosing to
continue my education at Stuyvesant High
School was equivalent to never being a
professional ballet dancer but what a
decision means to an adult and what it
means to a fourteen-year-old are not the
same thing when I chose high school over
ballet school I was not thinking about
closing my options for the future but
about who I wanted to be hanging out
with at that moment after graduating
from Stuyvesant I moved to London to
prove to myself that I could reach my
goal of being a professional ballet
dancer and I did eventually joining the
state ballet of Berlin as a member of
the corps de ballet however I didn't
reach the goal that I was less aware of
the goal of feeling like an insider in
the ballet community it was not until I
arrived at GS that I was able to
simultaneously embrace the aspects of me
that came from both of my worlds after
all everyone at GS defines themselves in
multiple ways we are students and
parents students and workers students
and religious scholars students and
soldiers students and artists this is
not merely a tolerated fact it is a
treasured one college is a time of
exploration expansion and learning but
for many of us this type of growth
became possible only because GF allowed
us to feel and to know that here we are
accepted as who we are and valued for
all of who we are in the year before
enrolling at GS I volunteered as a
teacher of two year olds with special
needs a new interest began to take shape
and even though I had never worked with
children before it felt more natural to
me than anything I had done with this
new passion rapidly developing going to
college suddenly began to feel right I
became a full-time preschool teacher at
the same time that I began my studies at
GS needless to say when my developmental
psychology professor asked for examples
of just about anything I was very
prepared I began to believe that I might
want to be a child psychologist but at
first I lacked confidence in my ability
to perform the more academic aspects of
that career psychological research was
an unknown to me and I imagined that I
would dislike it finding it one step
removed from real human experience in
order to test that theory I tried to get
as much research experience as possible
never have I been so excited to prove
myself so wrong the way in which I
became familiar with research was deeply
tied to human experience because
research was the passion and the life's
work of my professors here at Columbia
if the studies i read did not
immediately jump off the page in a
meaningful way I had only to walk to the
front of the room or go to office hours
in order to speak directly to the
authors in my meetings with Tori Higgins
my research mentor and an extremely
influential social psychologist the
topics we covered in meetings ranged
from the methodology for my thesis to
ballet traveling and marriage my
research experiences here convinced me
that it was within my reach to perform
both the clinical and the scientific
elements of a career as a psychologist
and they prepared me well for the next
step toward that goal when I cross this
campus for the first time I remember
thinking that it could never be mine it
was too grand to beautiful and intended
for students six years younger than I
was I told myself that I would borrow
the campus just for a short time while I
got my education and then give it back
unassuming to the traditional students
the confidence that I slowly gained a GS
did not come from me it came from you my
fellow graduates as I met more and more
GS students I couldn't help but be proud
to be one of them every student I met
had an inspiring life story and one told
with confidence and self awareness I
reveled in the fact that GS students
accepted the complexity of themselves
and of others as I spent more time with
my classmates I became aware of other
commonalities among us despite our
incredibly varied reasons for delaying
our education each of us has had to
overcome something sometimes ourselves
to begin our college education whether
our challenges were internal or external
they were the battles each one of us has
had to fight and we did and we overcame
perhaps this history is what gives us
another one of our shared qualities
perspective the challenges we face at
Columbia are not insignificant and
students at GS are well prepared to
place those challenges within a broader
perspective there were times when it was
only with difficulty that I was able to
do this in these moments I inevitably
evoked my experiences dancing the shades
seen in the ballet lobby Adair this
famous scene features the corps de
ballet women they appear on the stage
one by one at the top of a tall platform
and proceed to create a long line of
identical forms as they danced very
slowly down the ramp and on to the stage
let me tell you what this entails for
the dancers while in the wings we climb
up a rickety metal ladder one after the
other blinded by the white 22 of the
girl on top of us arriving at the top of
the ramp we step onto the stage and
proceed to balance on one leg on the
extremely narrow soul of a pointe shoe
while bending forward on a downhill
because of this experience every time I
had a big exam or a big speech at
Columbia and I felt my nerves tightening
into something like dread I would ask
myself one simple question okay Kyra
where would you rather be here or in the
wings preparing for by adair
and I would newly appreciate the fact
that exams are taken sitting down that
sneakers are infinitely more comfortable
than pointe shoes and that College does
not involve white to juice I believe
that the most important thing that we
share as general studies students is the
fact that we never take a college
education for granted we know that
studying here at Columbia is an
opportunity and one for which we never
forget to be grateful taking advantage
of this opportunity is not something
that we could have done alone I think it
is fair to assume that all of us are
eternally grateful for the family
members and the friends who believed in
us and supported us in whatever ways
they could they have shared our joy at
the high points helped us through the
hardest moments and they have allowed us
to define quality time as use it close
to me while i study and ignore you as
general studies students are shared view
of education as a golden opportunity
brings us together in concrete ways I
met some of my closest friends at GS in
a statistics class we became friends not
because we shared similar backgrounds or
interests but because we shared cheezits
on thursday nights at 8pm when all of
our classmates and RTA had abandoned the
stats lab there we all were a small
group of GS students helping each other
to apply formulas use new fangled stats
software and yes sharing vending
machines
today as the GS class of 2011 we take
our first step away from GS 311 steps in
311 different directions we take with us
an ability to honor the things that make
us unique and an ability to be equally
proud of our strengths and our struggles
our paths were not simple or direct our
plans were not always carried out
exactly as we imagined we can appreciate
that there is no timeline and no
blueprint for achievement I have no
doubt that going forward we will
continue to define and create our own
opportunities and to achieve in our own
ways as we move away from this phase of
our lives we will not stop learning we
are a group of people who know how to
learn in many ways and I urge us to
continue our education formally or
informally I know that wonderful things
await us but I know something else that
is almost more important I know that
when the difficult times strike as they
always do we will be the ones who know
how to turn difficulty into an
opportunity to turn a failed plan into a
better plan today our graduation is not
the fulfillment of a plan it is the
fulfillment of a dream class of 2011
congratulations
congratulations to the graduates your
family's loved ones and friends you
embody in a unique and compelling way
the mission and vision of GS and
Columbia I hope you will stay involved
with your Columbia family for many years
to come I invite you all to continue the
celebration at the class day reception
to be held under the far tent directly
to your right and my left I ask our
guests to remain seated while the
president's party and the candidates
file out will the candidates please
stand